4th gen Intel Xeon scalable processors
IBM natiza performance server as a
service on AWS and IBM eyes Merlin all
on this episode of IBM Tech now what's
up y'all my name is Ian and I am back to
bring you the latest and greatest news
and announcements about IBM technology
hope all of you had a wonderful and
restful holiday break and you're coming
back refreshed and ready to learn about
some tech to get the ball rolling in the
new year let's talk processors we are
thrilled to announce that IBM is
bringing the long anticipated 4th gen
Intel Xeon scalable processors onto IBM
Cloud infrastructure
Intel's latest chip design makes vital
use of core CPU resources with
integrated accelerators and rooted
protections to help speed up safeguarded
data for fast networking and boosted
Analytics
the 4th gen Intel Xeon microarchitecture
is now available on IBM Cloud bare metal
servers and will continue to expand its
footprint throughout multiple IBM Cloud
platforms into 2023
the processors on our bare metal servers
are designed to deliver true optimized
performance across some of the fastest
growing workload types this includes
artificial intelligence machine learning
analytics Cloud microservices networking
databases and Storage
we're also announcing an exclusive Early
Access beta program for IBM Cloud
virtual servers for VPC featuring the
4th gen processors
to learn more and apply to be part of
the beta program click the link in the
description of this video
next up we're also excited to announce
the tech preview availability of IBM
natiza performance server as a fully
managed service on AWS
IBM natiza performance server provides a
high performance Cloud native data
warehouse that is designed for scalable
analytics and insights and it is
accessible in a single massively
parallel processing platform as a new
fully managed service on AWS the teaser
brings trusted scalable and price
performance analytics to your data in
the cloud
including capabilities like ultimate
cost control with granular elastic
scaling in the cloud simple frictionless
Cloud deployment collaboration across
secure and governed data High
availability for your analytics and
automated Administration in the cloud
to get started with the tech preview of
IBM natiza performance server as a fully
managed service on AWS hit the link
below
to wrap things up today let's talk a
little about Merlin and I don't mean
King Arthur's buddy Merlin or
modernization engine for life cycle
integration is IBM eyes newest product
to assist with application modernization
and devops pipeline process development
it's browser-based and it helps improve
the IBM I platform by enabling you to
easily interact with the applications it
also supports you with state-of-the-art
interfaces for performing modernization
and updating applications
security is always of the utmost
importance and the tools ensure that
applications are written securely across
the entire development life cycle
through built-in automated security and
testing features Merlin even supports
both newer and older versions of RPG
code making the IBM I platform more
accessible to different types of
developers with varied experience to
learn more about Merlin get your hands
dirty hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now